oooh it's gonna need more the skin cream
to clear that up
[Applause]
[Music]
over Duke dr. who review time the but
before I get to it I am gonna mention
the sponsor because I do have one for
this particular episode the wonderful
folks over at the radio versus the
Martians podcast this is fronted by Mike
Gillis and Casey Doran they are a
fantastic pair of nerds and actually
they tend to consider the show The
McLaughlin group for nerds they have on
guests they talk about pretty much any
nerdy thing that's going on in their
head superheroes comics sci-fi fantasy
on occasion it runs the gamut it's
always interesting it's sometimes
insightful it's oftentimes very funny
especially their little podcast mini
venture hasa podcast LaVista baby which
goes through every single film that on
Arnold Schwarzenegger ever made that's
been quite a trip so far
so check out radio versus the Martians
calm or look them up on whatever you
used to listen to podcasts and now I get
to talk about the Lazarus experiment
which is one of those episodes that I
really never did go back and revisit
after seeing it the first time because
it was just like okay so that was a
thing that I saw and having seen it
again that continues to be yet just kind
of a thing that I saw like it this is
the kind of one that's bad in a really
not entertaining to talk about way
because when when a net well whether
it's an episode of Doctor Who or movie
or whatever when something's bad it gets
me worked up there's a certain energy I
can draw from that but when an episode
is just boring which is honestly what
the Lazarus experiment is that's hard to
do much with in terms of you know
finding things to say about it there's a
dog that I am watching today that is
down there and is snoring so if you hear
that I apologize I'm not gonna wait
the guy up not my dog but just watching
him anyways sorry that was bugging me so
yeah the Lazarus experiment so we have
Mark Gatiss doing a guest appearance and
I do like Mark Gatiss I think I at least
in terms of his Doctor Who output I tend
to like him better as an actor then I do
as a as a writer and he's he's fine in
this like there's something that doesn't
quite ring true to me about dr. Lazarus
and the degree to which he kind of
embraces the the monstrousness that
occurs to him
like he never seems horrified by what
he's become which to me is weird and I
feel like we didn't get to know him well
enough to for that to track for that to
make sense cuz I mean it would take a
very specific person to be totally cool
with becoming what he becomes and
killing people in order to keep himself
going and we don't get to know this guy
what like we get to know alright he's a
bit of a sleaze we get that right off
the bat but that's that's a leave to go
from slightly sleazy guy to totally cool
with turning into a monster and killing
people like that's a leap so there's an
inherent fundamental disconnect right
there as far as the whole thing goes the
other thing about this is is obviously
the monster self the monster shows up
around the halfway mark of the episode
and we see a lot of it and the results
of the thing seeing it it the effects
the the ambition of the concept
outstripped what they were capable of
doing and it is it is along the lines of
the Scorpion King from The Mummy Returns
it is that kind of uncanny valley does
not look like it's existing in the same
space whatsoever kind of effect but even
beyond that I think the very design of
the thing is fundamentally flawed
because well I have a very hard time
buying two things one if the entire
concept of this thing is that it's
somehow locked away in our DNA and
because it's an evolutionary track that
we didn't take I think they went way too
far away from human for me to buy that
as an ex
nation like I would have bought it a lot
more if the doctor had said somehow he
had he must have been he must have
gotten like some non-human alien DNA
that he was messing with I would I would
have bought the result so much more of
it was that so the explanation doesn't
track with that and the other thing is
he's he becomes so big that and I mean
lots of things sort of break I forget
what the what the law is but that there
is there is a physical property law that
like you can't you can't become more
than what you're made out of so like
there's plenty of shows and movies or
whatever that kind of break that
especially in the sci-fi fantasy realm
in terms of somebody like suddenly
becoming big and monstrous and like well
you know you couldn't actually do that
because you're only made of so much
stuff in the first place but I'm usually
able to swallow that this is so far off
the scale on that particular thing that
I'm just like no no and again it just
makes me disconnect from the entire from
the entire thing like I can't take this
monster seriously and again it doesn't
look good it's I feel like in some ways
it's the it's the new who equivalent of
the murca which if you know your classic
who is from warriors of the deep and was
an effect that was so bad it honestly
probably contributed over the long term
to the cancellation of Doctor Who
because there was a guy at the head of
the BBC who did not like Doctor Who at
all and he would frequently cite this
creature and that stuff that creature
and that story as to why the show was no
good and I feel like in some ways this
is the modern CGI equivalent of that
it's like you're you what you wanted to
do was was too big for the means that
you had to try and execute it with and
and you didn't even shoot around that
you're showing us this thing a lot
because like at least was something like
the werewolf from tooth and claw like
that wasn't particularly convincing
effects either but they at least knew to
keep that in the shadows for a decent
chunk of that there were a few shots
that I'm like no you should have put
more darkness over that but they at
least tried to hide a little bit this
one it's just like there
I'm like you shouldn't be showing us
that that much of this thing so even
beyond that though even beyond the
failure of the effect and it's a pretty
big failure of the effect conceptually
this this is a story that very obviously
doesn't fill the time because it has a
very natural climax with about ten
minutes left to go and it makes up those
last ten minutes by going oh we thought
he was dead he's not now we have to
defeat him again and there's nothing new
that comes of that like at all the even
the doctor confronting Lazarus in the
church nothing about that interaction
tells us anything more about Lazarus or
about the doctors feelings about
somebody like him than their earlier
interactions did so we get no new
information about any of the characters
involved and we're just gonna do we're
just gonna fight this same monster again
like that it's so blatantly padded that
the that the story reached a natural
conclusion with ten minutes left to go
or like ah do another last fight it's
yeah this was a really thin flimsy idea
that they did not know how to get a full
episode out of and it is painfully
obvious so is there anything any good in
this the doctor and Martha are both
solid and this they're pretty good I
like I I think the I think Tennant
actually has a pretty good showing in
this overall in terms of confronting
Lazarus and all that but like it's not
enough to save the episode and the
little bits we get of say Martha's
mother are interesting partially in how
she both evokes and also contrasts with
Jackie because this like as the doctor
himself knows this is the second mother
of someone traveling with him who has
smacked him but so it does it VOC that
but I still get a very different vibe
off of her that I did off of Jackie that
said I don't love that we're kind of
revisiting this whole the family that
gets left behind domestic angle cuz I
don't I'm not a huge fan of it in
general and I'm not sure there's
anything about it when they do with
Martha that is any better about
was done when they did it with rose but
again I do appreciate that these that
these characters are different from from
Jackie and from roses family so you know
kind of a mixed bag as far as that goes
like I guess if I were to somewhat of I
don't like that they're repeating the
concepts but the characters they're
repeating the concepts with are fine so
I guess that I don't even I think if I'd
even get anything else to say on this
like I've seen some people say some
places like that this is a very classic
who kind of story you know doctor shows
up has a monster tries to feed it but
like it's really not because usually
there'd be more of uh there'd be more of
a proper build-up and you wouldn't spend
literally half the story just running
away from the thing and it's just this
feels more like a like a bad filler
episode of something like no I was gonna
say Buffy the Vampire Slayer Slayer no
not even that cuz even Buffy would have
done a longer build-up to the reveal of
the thing or would have found something
to do with the downtime between
confronting it and this thing just
doesn't it's it you know what it feels
like it feels like a mediocre
installment in a slasher franchise it
feels like I don't know Friday the 13th
number seven that's what it feels like
it feels like here we are here's the
thing that's gonna kill a bunch of
people you have fun with this right
well string it along until we hit the
required run time it like that's that is
that is what it feels like and it feels
very undoctored who and it's it's boring
for all the big monster running around
explodes the explosions even you know
fairly impressive but it's boring
it doesn't help because it's
conceptually boring the execution
doesn't work on multiple levels and
there's just it just doesn't work but
again not in a way that light can get me
angry just in a way that's like that was
dull and kind of a waste of time and I'm
not sure I've got anything else to say
about it so that's the Lazarus
experiment
yeah it's a thing that I watched don't
think I'll do that again
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are
drops on me down the comments let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff to do cuz
buttons links patreon P o box Amazon
wishlist cuz my birthday is this month
they're all down in the description if
you want to give them a look plus also
you know the link for our radio versus
the Martians give them a listen there's
your little reminder so any of the links
down in the description give them a look
give them a click but it's also ok if
you don't because I'm not gonna tell you
what to do cuz at the end of the day you
folks are the council I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]